the people of dhaka said they have had
enough they're out on the streets of
bangladesh capital to show their anger
against rising food prices
a leftist alliance supported by
opposition parties has called for a
nationwide strike
[Applause]
for the past few months prices of
essentials in bangladesh have gone up a
lot and the majority of people are now
suffering we made several demands to the
government to bring these under control
but the government's not paid much
attention to
in response the government has launched
a nationwide food subsidy program for
about 10 million people
if they would provide all essential
items together then it would be easier
for us we can't afford to buy items from
the market prices are too high but these
rations are not always available
despite the country having enough food
stock on hand consumers are having to
pay higher prices for some food items
than those in western countries
prices of essential food item has gone
up in recent months in bangladesh a
kilogram of sugar
a litter of cooking oil costs more here
than in european union
it doesn't cost more here than in some
american cities making it extremely
difficult for an average wage owner to
make ends meet
even families who are on a good income
are now struggling
prices are too high in the market for
all essential items for middle class
people like us it's beyond our budget
now as we have limited income it will be
good if the government takes measures to
reduce prices
economist family decathlon says a small
group of traders who want to create a
monopoly is part of the problem market
mechanism does not work properly we have
seen that a small group of traders
influences
and in fact controls
the market prices
so therefore there's a need for
efficient market management by the
policy makers
the government says it's cracking down
on corrupt businesses
we will not accept and allow any kind of
illegal malpractice in the market and
for that we urge the relevant
authorities to take necessary measures
and government consumer protection
agencies have already started to work on
this
analyst fear rising inflation high fuel
cost and a protracted ukraine war will
continue to affect the cost of living in
bangladesh and the country may
experience more protest and unrest in
the coming days chanvit choudhary
al-jazeera dhaka